There is no pretense of consistency.
I mean on that side of the aisle it's
like we're going to throw out the
following 17 completely contradictory
rules and then we'll tell you which rule
is operative in any given moment.
So you know,
I was going to throw out this concept of
the Hilbert problems for social justice.
So one of them is um,
you cannot understand me because my
experience is too different and you must
understand me because mine
is so important, right?
Or we are all similar enough
that any deviation from 50,
50 shows you the amount of sexism in a
workforce and we are all so different
that once you include women, uh,
in previously male occupations,
you will see a great benefit
because of the diversity of opinion.
We'll see there are all these
self contradictory couplets
that you have to agree
to.
Well that's the weird thing is who
assume that I just buy all of your stuff.
I think we've made a
terrible tactical error.
We fought these bad
ideas rather than saying,
maybe we should just accept all of your
bad ideas and then show you what kind of
weird world. Yes, no, no, no, no.
You can't do that because they don't
make sense. You can't say, oh yeah,
they make sense. Men, how do I know when
you're serious? Well, but that's fine.
Just let those through. Things
fail. But that's my point is,
is that by showing the
internal, this is in, in,
in mathematics we call this reductio ad
absurdum that once you take on too many
different points,
you show the conflicts showing that
those things can't all be true.
There's no way in which if
I accept all of your ideas,
I can run anything. So, you know,
take this thing about a trans exclusion
from Victoria's secret, right?
Oh, you didn't hear methods. Oh God.
So the idea is that the Victoria secret
lingerie division head had to step down,
um, where there was a scandal in the
background that somebody had said,
we don't actually want a trans people
walking the Victoria's secret runway.
Right.
And so very interesting.
You have a company that is dedicated to
the commercial exploitation of humans as
sexual objects for the
privilege of the male gaze.
And now you're angry that it doesn't
include trans into that exploited class.
So just without,
without getting into whether this
makes good economic sense or anything,
there's just the issue
of self contradiction.
But isn't that a reductionist
view of what Victoria secrets is?
Isn't it possible that a woman can feel
empowered and sexy if she's wearing
lingerie and it's not just
to the exploiting of the
male gaze that it just, they,
that she appreciates looking attractive.
Wonderful. So take that off. Right,
exactly. So the idea is that
you're both going to say, um,
uh,
that that's a positive female empowerment
issue and it's a terrible male
exploitation as you at the same time,
terrible mountain exploitation issue.
Like what if a guy likes,
what if women decide universally,
they like guys who wear leopard skin
underwear and guys start wearing leopard
skin tidy whitey underwear. Well, this
is sexual selection, but it, but yes,
but what's the difference between
that and women wearing lingerie?
If with women wear lingerie and they
do it because they like to be an
interesting stat and they like to be
more attractive to accentuate their
attractive than the sexual self.
Objectification is an interesting issue.
Is that an issue of empowerment
or is it an issue of oppression?
It could certainly be if a woman's health,
do you take the take that all on?
Why does it have to be exploitation
though? That's the question,
but what I'm trying to say
is you've t some point,
you've made too many arguments.
There's this concept called the
principle of explosion in mathematics.
The principle of explosion says if you
can get one contradiction through airport
security,
you can blow up the universe that as soon
as you allow a single contradiction in
the unity of knowledge,
everything can be proven right.
So everything becomes meaningless.
So the game in some sense in
mathematics is frequently to say, well,
let's take all of those beautiful
things that you believe.
So you've just enunciated some,
I've annunciated some throw them all in
instead of saying what's true and what
isn't true,
you say are these compatible and
these ideas are clearly incompatible.
So for example,
one of the tricks that I use is to look
at advertising for women to women and
what phrases get used.
So if you use the phrase turn heads
the summer in quotes and put it into a
search engine,
you'll find all sorts of revealing outfits
that are intended to court the male
gaze. You say, well maybe
that's not really the male gaze.
Then you put it in a phrase like make
him drill and that will be used to market
to women.
And so this issue about can we at least
get to a point where we're talking about
the internal contradictions
of your position.
Like I don't even want to
get into what my position is.
The first thing that's scaring me is that
you've said so many things so strongly
and so dogmatically and this
doesn't have to be about gender.
It could be about race, it
could be about class. But once,
once you've said too many
things, then I can say, look,
I don't see any way of squaring
all of your positions and it's not,
it doesn't even have to do with me.
Right.
I think that's where
we haven't gone to yet.
So you think letting them come up with
as many preposterous things as possible
and then once it gets to a
position where they, the,
the idea's contradict each other, expose
that. Well that's, that's my point,
which is once you've told me all of
your principals, then I'm going to say,
great,
I'm confused.
Do you feel that I have to understand you
or that I can't understand you because
I don't know which is operative in
the situation. Tell me the rule,
how I decide which principle that
you've stated governs this situation.
Right.
If one last point about that,
I don't want to have to refer to
you where you say, well you bring,
you bring me each individual and I will
tell you which principals operative in
which principals inoperative
that doesn't work.
I want you to list your principles,
enlist your mechanisms for resolving
the conflicts within your principles.
And then once you've done that, we can
actually evaluate what you're saying,
but at the moment it requires you as
an oracle to tell me which of your many
contradict you.
Seemingly contradictory positions is
operative in every particular case.